At first glance, the Focus Electric looks like any other Ford Focus.
You can really only tell by the few badges that are on the exterior of the vehicle.
Instead of running on gasoline,...
...there's an electric motor up-front and a battery pack in the back.
Inside are lots of displays like a brake coach feature...
...that help you get the most from regenerative braking.
Inside, it's like any top-level Focus.
Nicely finished.
Optional leather seats are supportive.
MyFord Touch is standard.
It's overcomplicated and annoying with some busy screens.
The backseat is pretty snug...
...like the normal Focus.
However, in the Focus EV, the battery pack takes up quite a bit of cargo space.
The Focus Electric is an enjoyable, efficient car to drive.
It finally shows that going green can be fun.